[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
happy wednesday everyone so did you hear
the squad they demanded something
i know
let's hope it's four one-way tickets to
cuba
really why do they keep demanding so
much from america when they could get
everything they want from akami paradise
90 miles south what whiners
terrorists don't make this many demands
when they kidnap someone they work for
us not the reverse but now they're
lashing out at biden after he said the
white house has no plans to extend the
pause on federal student loan repayments
gee i wonder if aoc has over seventeen
thousand dollars in student loan debt
i have
over seventeen thousand dollars in
student loan debt we have a moral
obligation an economic obligation a
political obligation to cancel student
loan debt
cancel did you get that we are morally
obligated to pay off this idiot's debt
sorry lady if the members of the squad
were morally obligated then one of them
couldn't marry her brother
red meat
so she's talking about her college
education debt where she majored in dumb
with a minor at ignorance
and it's the debt that she agreed to pay
but now she wants you to cover the tab
but okay i'll play if i pay your debt
then you've got to pay my mortgage how's
that for a trade numbnuts why do you get
a special carve out and not me you
actually have more power than i do you
got the privilege and now you want the
perks how about returning that dress you
wore to the gala that's 20k right there
so we don't owe you a single penny
i only wish there was someone around
who's even dumber than her
i worked full time
monday through friday and took weekend
classes to get my law degree and still
close to two hundred thousand dollars in
debt
ah whose fault is that
you brimming cup of piping hot stupid
if she could work hard to get her degree
why can't she work hard to pay for her
degree write a book hell even jessie
waters can do that
and now you expect us to wipe that
financial slate clean she makes 174
grand a year off taxpayers and for her
that's not enough but it does raise a
point why do the dumbest people have the
most degrees as a matter of fact the
really smart ones don't have any
einstein quit high school bill gates
dropped out so did james woods and david
geffen both zuckerberg and steve jobs
left school without diplomas too what
does that tell you at least these people
have made huge contributions to our
world unlike you adults those pieces of
paper we call diplomas are the only
reason to mistake the
squad for being smart
and sure maybe they got ripped off but
not by you or me they didn't go to the
university of gutfeld
which is free
and voted number one party school three
years in a row
i am accepting applicants
but you have to send a photo
they got ripped off by the colleges who
saw how easy it was to get student loans
from banks tagging these brain-dead
bozos with absurd interest rates who
would think a system where 18 year olds
with no income getting hundred thousand
dollar loans would cause problems
the universities and the government did
they should give themselves an a for
absolutely incompetent
and didn't aoc get a degree in economics
i could clip my toenails for six months
put them in a bag and they would
understand inflation better than her
by the way i sell them on ebay to pay
off my college debt
that's enterprising now they try to
pretend that forgiving student debt
helps the poor except the people with
student debt are just like them pampered
upper middle class leftists who can
afford more stuff than you we've seen
aoc's dc apartment on instagram didn't
look like section 8 housing to me miss
cortez
they pretend to be the working class but
they expect the working class to bail
them out yet while they were racking up
debt with useless degrees the working
class were denied that opportunity
largely due to cost you bail these
idiots out you're literally taking money
from people who are worse off than them
i wonder how this would play out in the
real world
[Music]
just this please oh and uh he's gonna
pay for all these too
i don't know this lady all right come on
let's go let's go let's go even if i
wanted to i can't afford all this okay
whatever cool uh but you're not the one
who's late to her country club wine
tasting so
i can't afford a country club either
just take out a loan
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like a little new yorker cartoon
so how can these squad members do this
with a straight face maybe that's why
biden and pelosi had so much plastic
surgery
so here's an idea you want debt
forgiveness that actually doesn't help
the rich i got a plan i call it gutfeld
on wheels there are more people who rely
on cars for a living than a master's
degree in gender dysmorphia suddenly
their gas costs more more than 50 than
before their loans are roughly the same
as the student loans why not forgive
those loans for hard-working yanks
instead of your spoiled scholastic
i won't pick up the tab for some whiny
entitled creep but i'll pay off the
truck loan of some contractors
supporting a family or an ihop waitress
with two kids who moonlights as a
stripper and needs implants
i'm nothing if not a philanthropist
for giving an auto loan is way more
egalitarian than forgiving debt for
people who go to met galas and a tesla
but if you want loan forgiveness you're
not you can't come to us you got to go
to the schools
why punish the taxpayers they didn't
take your money the overpaid
administrators did their cost controls
are more non-existent than pete
butterjudge's breast pump
of course joe biden instead of leading
continues squirming a spineless void
ready for the picking he said it's up to
congress to help execute his plan to
cancel 10 grand worth of student loans
but only if the congress sends him a
bill
it's pretty convenient for this lame
trojan horse
speaking of horses we'd be better off
with mr ed running things at least he
could talk
but it could be that joe is playing dumb
but come to think of it there would be
no playing involved
welcome tonight's guest he's so young he
still calls congress his summer job
north carolina gop congressman madison
concord
she's as smart as the whip she uses to
beat her co-host jose kennedy of hope's
business kennedy
she's like a string of old christmas
lights twisted and half of the time
never working boxes contributor captain
and as a child santa left him cookies on
christmas eve my massive sidekick and
the nwa world television champion
pirates
but kennedy but kennedy she took weekend
classes that should be enough reason to
pay her debt no there is no more
obligation there's no political
obligation there's no emotional
obligation there just isn't and i'm glad
people are finally catching on to the
ruse because college enrollment is down
and at community college it's down by
double digits that's because people have
figured out they don't get a lot after
they earn a four-year degree i
interviewed a writer from the wall
street journal last week and he told me
that men are leaving college in droves
so it's now 60 40 men to women in
college because guys are considered the
enemy and they've also done the cost
benefit analysis they would rather start
working at 18 and get a jump on the
competition and then when you decide
what you want to do and you want a
specific degree to help you get a better
job
then you go to college that might be a
better way for a lot of people yeah and
you have money saved up for it you don't
have to rely on the government and then
come and ask taxpayers for a bailout uh
congressman i realized what makes you
different from tom brady oh
you're better looking and you're faster
now i'll tell you people will attack him
all the time for and i think it was tony
romo who decreased his speed rating but
he gets more first downs than than romo
ever did so i i believe in him but i'll
tell you yes i think that these
federally subsidized student loans are
the biggest lie my i feel bad for my
generation because they've been told
that the way to get ahead in life is to
go get a college degree i'm a college
dropout my chief of staffs are called oh
really absolutely where did i drop out i
dropped out after my first year oh wow
yeah it's i i it's
so asinine i mean you get there and it's
great to be well-rounded and learn all
the history and all this stuff but once
you leave you realize that this doesn't
actually get me ahead in life when you
could just go start your own business
and make money actually build something
with you what did you do when you when
you dropped out what it was the first
thing i went into real estate investment
tax foreclosures it was awesome but i
i'll tell you
the thing the problem is though
you realize the system's broken when an
18 year old can not get a 10 000
business loan but they're able to get a
100 000 student loan that will do them
no good in the long run so this is awful
but for aoc who i guarantee does not
tithe in any way to be able to say oh
well ten percent of my yearly income is
a ridiculous amount for me to be
considered to pay yeah it's 174 thousand
dollars a year can't pay back 17 000
that's insane it is insane do you talk
to her much no um no i i don't do you
hang out with the squad i i do not i
it's oh yeah and i'll tell you a lot of
them will tell you you know the person i
am on media and on social media that's
that's just work but i'm able to be
friends behind the scenes and when one
of them told me that i almost looked
back and said oh yeah no that's i
totally understand that works worked but
then i realized wait a minute you are
leading my generation down a dystopian
hell path to destroy our entire country
lie to the american people and just make
us a socialist country so i don't want
to be your friend in any way i don't
want to spend any time with you then i
left you know well you know
i just want to point out he said
dystopian hell path and he didn't go to
college
there you go somebody has a word a day
calendar
better than college i say cats you know
what drives me crazy the cancel student
debt thing they never tell you what it
means like it always sounds like some
kind of weird being is going to cancel
it and all the money goes away
i say that i've been saying that for
years i'll send you the receipts later
because it's not canceling it's forcing
other people to pay for it right and
there's no moral obligation
to you know well taxation's not just
theft because the cops arrest you they
have guns taxation is armed robbery
so there's no moral obligation to you
know promote more armed robbery pay for
your own
yes
these are the least deserving people of
a bailout i rather bail out the banks
again or the bloods or the crips
pirates i would probably hold off on
bailing out the bloods and crips you
might want to win on that one okay but
uh
you know it's funny to me that as they
sit there with their first world
problems i get speaking fees of 50 000
but i can't pay a 70 000 loan back you
know what about the mom and dad who for
who said hey you know what no vacation
or repaid we're putting our money away
to send our son and daughter to school
and they they did the due diligence they
did the work they sacrificed all that
money and they paid for their child to
go to school and whether they graduated
or not graduated do they get that money
back they i would rather pay them
because they made the choice
and then they didn't they chose it's
about accountability which is a
four-letter word to the woke and the
squad because they don't want to be
accountable but those americans who put
it on their back to put their kids
through school
it's a slap in their face right and it
should show up when they vote it's like
you know what the thing is
if you if the government actually did
that let's say they did some kind of
weird lottery where they just randomly
paid people who actually worked nights
and and got to that would be an
incentive to pay it off yeah i mean it's
not even just parents to the to the
person in the relationship who helped
put their significant other through med
school or whatever and then they left
them so should they get a check yes but
no no the ones who actually got free
money
apparently squandered it miserably with
their education they should get bailed
out it's it's as ridiculous as just
calling yourself the squad can i quickly
call aoc out on something that she said
she said that 67 of jobs require
education beyond high school that's
nonsense because 66 of the people in the
country don't have college degrees so
it's like
that's one of those statistics like
she's just lying she's literally making
something up and no if you're going to
make more over the course of your
lifetime that puts you into a different
privileged class
you should absolutely be paying for the
other things that people who really
struggle can't afford like yes exactly
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else